but I just feel like Andrew Tate always
preached the importance of how to
recognize a good woman so don't you
think he could have used that skill set
to just find that good woman and focus
on her only because I get it like is
you're putting your um like you said put
in your chances just on one many women
is better than one but now they're in a
situation
there's no such thing in my opinion
there's no such thing as a good woman I
know that sounds crazy and the reason is
because any even a good woman can get in
the wrong group of friends even a good
woman can start following the wrong
people online listening to the wrong
music and make a decision when she's
angry it's not that every like 50 of
women file for divorce it doesn't mean
50 of women are evil but women are a lot
more easily influenced like they're like
10 times more likely to get divorced if
their friends get divorced